bonsoir à toutes et tous et merci de
nous rejoindre sur tv fil 78 pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés le débat
de ce soir porte sur la réforme du
collège
pourquoi ça coince pour ka sat cause
toujours
vous pouvez réagir sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions les vacances
sont passées mais la mobilisation se
poursuit dans le second degré 1-1 pas là
à l'appel intersyndical à la grève a été
lancé pour le 17 septembre pour un
retrait pur et simple du projet de najat
vallaud belkacem pourquoi la majorité
des syndicats enseignants reste-t-elle
opposés à cette réforme
que contient vraiment le texte qu est-ce
qui va concrètement changer dans
l'organisation des collèges dans le
travail des enseignants et dans l'emploi
du temps des collégiens le collège
sera-t-il plus égalitaire avec cette
réforme pour répondre à ces questions
quatre invités autour de la table
sandrine grillé d'abord qui est
secrétaire général du syndicat
d'enseignants se gainent cfdt à
l'académie de versailles vous avez été
professeur d'anglais au collège pendant
six ans maintenant vous êtes en guise et
bonsoir
enfin jacques jodo au co secrétaire
départemental du syndicat d'enseignants
snes fsu pour les yvelines donc le snof
le snes fsu c'est le syndicat
majoritaire dans l'enseignement
secondaire tout genre bonsoir guelque et
huile membres du bureau fédéral du parti
socialiste est conseillère municipale à
ils encourent bonsoir et enfin nicolas
tardy joubert membres du bureau du parti
chrétien-démocrate des yvelines bonsoir
alors on va commencer avec une question
pour vous monsieur jeux d'eau puisque
vous appeler à une grève intersyndicale
avec d'autres syndicats le 17 septembre
alors dites-nous simplement pourquoi
avez-vous lancé cet appel à la grève
cet appel à la grève il poursuit le
mouvement déjà entamés au moins
de mai au mois de juin qui s'expliquait
par la façon dont le projet de réforme
avait été reçue dans les collèges dans
les salles des professeurs avec
étonnement déception colère même ce qui
avait expliqué une mobilisation forte
pour la grève du mois de mai dans la
foulée le gouvernement c'est 24%
seulement alors on va bongo barthel peut
pas polémiquer sur sur les chiffres 24%
s'il ministère veut s'en tenir à ce
chiffre très bien pour lui ça augure mal
de la suite vous savez c'est un peu
comme pour les chiffres de
manifestations est ce qu'on prend le
nombre de collègues attendu ce jour là
où le de collègues dans l'établissement
les 24 % du ministère ça se transforme à
plus de 50% pour les organisations
syndicales quoi qu'il en soit au delà
des au delà des chiffres il ya une vraie
colère en salle des professeurs dans les
dents dans les collèges
parce que cette réforme n'était pas
celle celle attendue dans la foulée donc
le gouvernement a assigné le lendemain
je crois les décrets
une façon de dire cette mobilisation on
en tient on n'en tient pas compte et
d'où la poursuite la poursuite du
mouvement les vacances n'ont pas
interrompu le processus dont il ya
effectivement un mot d'ordre de grève
pour la semaine prochaine jeudi le
jeudi17 se poursuivra le projet d'une
manifestation de grande ampleur on
l'espère au mois d'octobre si d'ici là
le gouvernement reste sur la position
qui a été annoncé par la ministre à la
fin du mois d'août c'est j'écoute mais
la réforme se fera donc
l' écoute mais normalement elle n'entend
pas alors justement le conseil supérieur
de l'éducation au mois d'avril dernier
sont évoquées à voter pour justement en
faveur de cette réforme 51 pour 25
contre et une abstention
alors comment expliquez vous qu'il ait
toujours des réticences à cette réforme
d'une part on accepte et puis après
finalement attention conseil supérieur
de l'éducation n'est pas composée
majoritairement dix organisations
syndicales enseignantes
c'est ça représente la société telle
qu'elle est il ya les associations de
parents d'élèves des associations
pédagogiques etc dont les enseignants
oui il ya des enseignants bien entendu
d'ailleurs sur le vote
il faut être très clair oui beaucoup de
syndicats enseignants ont voté contre
cette réforme et quelques-uns ont voté
pour et les associations de parents la
fcpe a voté pour et d'autres
associations pédagogiques ont voté pour
d'où ce vote
ultra majoritaire mais il faut faire
attention à la composition du cssa s'est
pas ce n'est pas un comité uniquement
d'enseignants
pourtant la promue à la mise de
l'éducation a largement commenté ce vote
bien sûr parce qu'il représente en fait
les usagers l'ensemble des usagers du
collège et qui trouve qu' il y a de
bonnes choses dans cette réforme même
question qu'à monsieur jo de monsieur
tardy joubert qu'est ce que vous
reprochez vous à 7
cette réforme est est-ce qu'il ya eu des
évolutions depuis depuis les vacances et
depuis ces deux mobilisations alors à
parler monsieur alors je crois qu'il
préférait un constat d'abord de de
départ c'est que quand on voit le
déficit de connaissances qu'ont pu d'un
quart ou presque un quart des élèves en
tout cas un élève sur cinq en matière de
deux français deux fondamentaux de
calcul d'écriture
de lecture en arrivé en sixième on
s'aperçoit que les méthodes de
l'éducation nationale ne sont pas les
bonnes
une baisse dramatique du niveau un petit
peu partout il faut vraiment faire en
sorte qu'on se forte du 80 % de réussite
au bac pour dire on veut avoir 100%
d'accessibilité à l'emploi et de
l'emploi et pour ça nous pensons qu'il
est nécessaire de d'abandonner le
collège unique et s'être forme ne
correspond pas à ce dont on a besoin
c'est quand même intéressant sur un plan
politique c'est de voir que un grand
nombre de ministres de l'éducation
nationale ça va de berrou à chevènement
pour un homme de droite ou de gauche
tous partis confondus partis confondus
la lune est limité de l'académie
française s'est prononcé contre cette
réforme
nous avons 74 % des enseignants qui sont
contre pourquoi ce parce que les
fondamentaux ne pourront pas être un
semis et aujourd'hui on va s'engager sur
des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire alors qu'il est
nécessaire de revenir aux fondamentaux
comment bien parler le français
mais les avocats bullaires et donc la
réforme qui est proposé ne correspond
pas à ce que l'on souhaite pour nos
enfants qui ont soif d'apprendre
yelle remettre quelques argue-t-il
rapidement et puis après je vous redonne
la parole
donc du coup par rapport à ce que disait
nicolas tard des joueurs à l'instant
cette réforme donc met de côté une
grande partie des fondamentaux français
les maths
non je ne crois pas que cette réforme
met de côté les fondamentaux d'ailleurs
quand on voit globalement les volumes
horaires ils sont à peu près à peu près
similaire entre ce qui s'était passé
avant est ce que ce qui va être mis en
oeuvre par la réforme
en revanche on change d'abord les
méthodes d'apprentissage avec je pense
on en reparlera ces enseignements
pluridisciplinaires transversaux c'est
une autre manière d'apprendre
voilà et puis tout ce qui est aussi en
sidim enseignement individualisé
donc c'est une méthode d'apprentissage
qui change pour essayer de
d'accrocher d'intéresser aussi les
élèves autrement et puis moi je voudrais
juste revenir sur le contexte le
contexte c'est 140 milles décrocheurs
par an c'est une inégalité qui minent
l'éducation aujourd'hui juste un chiffre
moi qui je trouve assez assez
intéressant en 2014
quand on prend le le retard en troisième
on à 28% des des fils et filles
d'ouvriers qui sont touchés contre 10 %
des enfants de cadres est donc là on
voit bien qu'il ya une nécessité de
réformes et qu'il faut pouvoir
s'attaquer à la manière dont est donc
est faite aujourd'hui à l'éducation pour
être justement plus d'égalité je crois
que c'est le coeur de cette réforme
c'est de dire que l'égalité pour tous ça
n'est pas l'ennemi de l'excellence et
qu'il faut pouvoir renforcer le collège
unique contrairement à ce que veut faire
la droite et qui a toujours été le
projet de la droite et lutter contre le
collège unique il faut pouvoir le
renforcer mes données à tous les élèves
les moyens d'accéder à l'excellence
jalousie oui je voulais juste relevé le
fait que la droite a quand même au
pouvoir c'est sous nicolas sarkozy noté
mike sous le sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy
quatre-vingt mille postes supprimés une
formation des enseignants massacrés
alors c'est bien que les représentants
de la droite aujourd'hui interviennent
pour dire qu'il ya des problèmes dans
l'éducation nationale
les problèmes de niveau et qu'il faut
les résoudre
mais je pense qu' il ferait mieux de se
faire tout petit sur cette question là
parce que la trace calais c'est le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
elle est traître elle va être très très
longues à effacer les critiques les
critiques que nous on apporte à 7 à
cette réforme ne sont pas de même nature
on a un petit peu tout mélanger au début
lorsque la réforme a été a été présenté
par les dieux latin on a parlé du grec
programme d'histoire de certaines on va
dire filières d'excellence ou genre les
classes bilan des classes européennes
etc etc
on a mis ça en avant alors que ces
périphériques par rapport au reste on
reste là de la réforme a on peut
regretté la disparition de ces
dispositifs et dire qu'au contraire elle
devrait peut-être fallu les élargir ça
ça vient du fait que la réforme se fait
à moyens constants
on pourra dire c'est mieux que la
réforme précédé les réformes précédentes
qui se sont faites en sabrant dans les
moyens celle ci se fait à peu près à
moyens constants donc les moyens il va
il faut bien les récupérer quelque part
et la disparition de ces dispositifs
s'explique en partie par sept par cette
nécessité mais le coeur de la réforme
il est il est ailleurs alors justement
le coeur de la réforme qu'elle est il le
coeur de la réforme qui peut répondre à
cette question puisque on va entendre
tout à l'heure ce que disaient les saint
quentinois et ce qu'ils en savent un
petit peu de cette réforme sur des murs
il pense qu'on va avoir des réponses
différentes puisque on n'a pas la même
interprétation des textes très
clairement il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant dans cette réforme c'est
ça se résume en d'un pourcentage c'est
20%
c'est à dire que 80% des horaires vont
être les mêmes dans tous les collèges de
france à chamonix ou attrape ou dans le
centre de saint germain en laye et puis
à 20% qui est laissée au choix des
équipes et nous gagne cfdt c'est ça qui
nous intéresse c'est la confiance aux
équipes et comment on peut dans un
établissement décidé de est bien de
travailler ensemble et de monter des
projets qui correspondent aux besoins
spécifiques des élèves de ce collège
parce que si je comprends bien 20% du
temps des enseignants va être tant
d'enseignants d'enseignement alors qui
va chapeauter tout ça qui va être parce
que c'est ce qui est reproché également
alors que le chef d'établissement peut
être entre guillemets le petit chef
oui et qu'il va choisir alors que nous
on pense que l'autonomie des
établissements c'est pas l'autonomie des
chefs d'établissement on est pour
clairement un renforcement du rôle du
conseil d'administration responsabiliser
les collègues et faire vivre la
démocratie locale
je pense que dans beaucoup d'endroits
le chef d'établissement n'est pas cet
être caricatural qui est contre les
enseignants je pense qu'on est capable
de travailler ensemble et après un
moment le chef d'établissement et là il
va être peut-être là pour impulser des
choses et le conseil d'administration
pour trancher le conseil
d'administration doit être un lieu où là
aussi les parents d'élèves sont présents
d'autres personnes sont présentes il n'y
a pas que des enseignants ça apporte un
éclairage extérieur et je pense que
c'est bien que l'ensemble des usagers du
collège s'empare de ça et peut-être et
des idées sur ces 20 % ses 20% vous
permettre de changer les méthodes
d'apprentissage
ça c'est une très bonne question en fait
parce que changer les méthodes
d'apprentissage ça ne se décrète pas
c'est signifie qu'il va falloir mettre
beaucoup de moyens en accompagnement des
équipes il va falloir que notre
employeur le faire que ministère il met
les moyens derrière pour former les
équipes accompagnées etc
et c'est là où moi j'ai quelques
craintes c'est à dire que pour former
les gens il faut du temps de l'argent
donc de l'argent et que et bien comme il
faut que tout soit mis en oeuvre en
septembre 2016
ça peut coincer en particulier dans
notre académie qui est énorme il ya
énormément de personnes est la forme et
c'est là où ça peut coincer mais si on
s'arrête à laon fait plus rien et que
l'interdît joubert alors 20%
d'enseignement qui vont pouvoir être
voilà dont vont pouvoir se saisira les
enseignants les chefs d'établissement
plutôt positif
vous ne voyez pas comme ça du tout je
pense qu'il faut se poser la question
différemment c'est à dire que il faut
pas raisonner gérer à court terme en dix
ans on a gagné une demi heure on a perdu
une demi heure on a 10 ou 20% gérer de
temps disponible
la question de fond qu'il faut se poser
c'est comment peut-on revenir à
l'apprentissage de matières
fondamentales sans mélanger toutes les
matières par exemple les enseignements
les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire on va avoir des
choses qui sont certainement très
intéressante mais est ce que c'est la
chose prioritaire que l'on veut
apprendre à nos enfants par exemple
en historien va travailler avec le prof
d'anglais qui va travailler également
avec eux
mais prof de mathématiques et ensemble
ils vont faire un projet voilà pour vous
c'est trop de mélanger c'est pas
efficace pour apprendre c'est pas
efficace par exemple gg vrai partager
avec vous que par exemple un professeur
de physique est français pourrait faire
quelque chose sur le développement
durable c'est certainement très
intéressants ou écrire un magazine sur
les machines à vapeur très intéressant
mais pendant ce temps là il y a un
déficit d'apprentissage de la langue
française
on le voit dans tous les questionnaires
géré par rapport à d'autres pays
maîtrise de sa propre langue on va
vouloir également faire apprendre dès la
5e
une deuxième langue vivante à tous alors
que beaucoup ce qu'elle jouera l'emblème
accueillis mais je rappelais que un
quart des enfants à peu près ne maîtrise
pas convenablement le français est donc
avant de se lancer dans jal aventure
comme celle là où on veut absolument
tout uniformiser il faut au contraire
essayer d'adapter aux besoins des
enfants et c'est pour ça que nous
revenons sur cette notion de suppression
du collège unique pour être au plus près
des besoins des enfants en fonction leur
capacité moduler les enseignements et
faire en sorte qu'il puisse être
préparée et avoir un avenir qui soit
digne de l'enseignement aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même un
constat global des chèques de trente ans
de politique
tout le monde sera d'accord sur le
constat en tout cas donc il fallait
marcher bonne mesure mais on l'a donnée
de manière un peu global alors on est
justement allez demander aux saint
quentinois leur avis sur cette réforme
ce qu'ils en savent peut-être et
on regarde on écoute ce que ça donne des
collèges
je trouve que c'est une aberration c'est
tout pourquoi pas ce qu'on voulait faire
faire supprimer latin dont les enfants
quand vie de chat du latin je vois pas
pourquoi on va leur supprimer latin ça
sert à quoi
mais inquiet parce que bon champ à
chaque fois les programmes mais on
supprime le latin je crois que j'aurais
peut-être pas il ya plus latins on va
enlever le latin c'est nul
et puis je croyais à mettre des langues
un peu plus tôt je sais que la
suppression des classes européennes
je sais que certains programmes ont été
revus j'ai l'impression que souvent on
est tiré par le bas et que cette réforme
va encore une fois de plus uniformisée
l'enseignement mais pas forcément dans
le bon sens
vous souhaitez réagir on a l'impression
que quand même la plupart des
incontinents collatéraux qu'on a
interrogés ne parle pas de tout ce qui
est autonomie etc etc
il ya deux mots clés qui ressortent en
général ses lattes un élan vivante
d'être en cinquième
c'est vrai que c'est ce qui me faisait
réagir c'est qu'on parle beaucoup
justement la suppression du latin ce qui
est absolument faux le latin n'est pas
supprimée c'est à dire que jusqu'ici
le latin et le grec était en général
demandé par une très faible minorité
d'élèves est ce que la réforme va faire
c'est permettre d'introduire ces langues
ces langues dans l'est justement ces
deux pays et permettre plus d'élèves de
découvrir avant la possibilité ensuite
d'approfondir dans des heures
complémentaires donc au contraire ça
n'est pas supprimé le latin c'est faire
en sorte que soient plus accessibles
plus démocratisé à l'ensemble des élèves
et je crois que la voie là on touche un
petit peu à questionnement sur cette
réforme où on a une espèce d'intox
voilà on a beaucoup parlé de cette
question du latin et en fait on cache
tout ce qu'il ya derrière et notamment
les questions d' approche méthodologique
qui moi me semble très importante
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
question des deux saisons des
enseignements transversaux
pluridisciplinaire kim hommes sont
extrêmement intéressants
par ailleurs ce n'est pas une nouveauté
c'est ce qu'on fait au lycée par exemple
avec les tpe et c'est une manière
justement de faire adhérer les élèves
d'apprendre autrement alors c'est sûr on
sort de ce conte et se connaissaient
classiquement avec un court une heure
une classe une matière non ça ne marche
plus
c'est ce que ça peut marcher pour
certains élèves mais je pense qu'un
produit diversifié les méthodes
d'apprentissage c'est un moyen de faire
adhérer les élèves et aussi de donner du
sens à l'enseignement mêlée par exemple
des mathématiques avec de la physique ou
une autre matière c'est aussi un moyen
de donner du sens et de paraître aux
élèves d'adhérer et d'avoir envie
d'apprendre que je pense que c'est ça
aussi l'ambition de la réforme c'est de
donner les moyens d'apprendre savoir à
prendre et donner envie d'apprendre et
donc je me suis mise à part des courants
conservateur réactionnaire qui vont
prier contre le collège unique les 80 %
etc etc
on peut aller dans le sens de ce que
vous venez de ce que vous venez de dire
si on fait abstraction de ce qui est la
réalité du métier la collecte d'une
gaine là un petit peu dit très bien si
les moyens sont derrière or ces pannes
ne sait pas très bien il ya des choses à
critiquer mais les moyens ne sont pas
sont pas derrière la réforme tient en
trois axes l'autonomie
l'interdisciplinarité et
l'accompagnement personnalisé
l'autonomie l'autonomie de qui
évidemment si c'est une autonomie qui
vient des équipes pédagogiques
elle même pour avoir plus de facilités
pour monter des projets qui se font déjà
les projets interdisciplinaires
c'est des choses qui existent déjà et
les équipes le font aujourd'hui dans des
conditions difficiles s'est pas pris en
compte c'est pas payer il ya de la
concertation etc etc
si l'autonomie c'est ça fait d'une
manière démocratique au sein des
établissements
sauf que les établissements ne
fonctionne pas comme ça c'est vrai que
tous les chefs d'établissement ne sont
pas d'affreux dictateur avec un
autoritarisme très marqué il y en a il y
en a les pressions de l'administration
existe également les conseils
pédagogiques sont pas des instances qui
aubry par leur part leur démocratie donc
cette autonomie elle peut conduire aussi
à ce que contrairement à ce que vous
disiez des différences soient très
marquée d'un établissement à un autre
et puis c c'est au pays ces fameux
projet interdisciplinaire
il faut bien se rendre compte que ces
horaires là contrairement aux tpe sont
pris sur les horaires disciplinaires six
mois professeur d'histoire-géographie
j'ai trois heures de cours avec une
classe que je travaille en
interdisciplinarité avec un collègue de
svt sur le développement durable
mais trois heures d'histoire géographie
deviennent de ces trois heures de svt
deviennent de également donc avait six
derniers qui l'ont en fait de
l'interdisciplinarité
ce n'est plus votre discipline que vous
faites donc vous donner raison à michel
sardou s'est pas tu sais pas tout à fait
ça c'est que l'interdisciplinarité est
on
un exemple c'est celui des tpe en lice
et c'est quelque chose de très très
intéressant c'est quelque chose qui
permet de développer des compétences un
travail en équipe un travail de
recherche
la réalisation d'un projet tout ça les
élèves apprennent des choses après une
des compétences
sauf qu'au niveau disciplinaire on s'en
rend bien compte c'est pas c'est pas là
que l'apprentissage et le est le plus
fort donc en lice et les tpe au fond ne
sommes pas trop mal parce que l'horaire
disciplinaire est maintenu et il y un
projet interdisciplinaire qui se met qui
se met en place
évalués au bac alors que la ces projets
interdisciplinaires comme si
l'interdisciplinarité était une solution
au problème ça passe peut-être en partie
en partie par là et le troisième point
l'accompagnement personnalisé juste
j'espère qu'on aura le temps d'aborder
aussi cette question parce que là aussi
c'est ce qui a été mis en place dans les
lycées par la réforme chatel on en a le
recul maintenant sur sur quelques années
c'est très très loin d'être ce alors
comment ça regarde justement
l'accompagnement personnalisé plus que
vous abordez le point l'accompagnement
personnalisé c'est quelque chose qui a
été présenté comme on va donner deux ou
trois heures d'accompagnement
personnalisé à chaque élève
chaque élève va bénéficier de d'un
certain nombre d'heures d'accompagnement
personnalisé qui peut être du soutien
qui peut être de la remédiation qui peut
être de l'approfondissement en fait
c'est s'adapter à chaque élève qui
pourrait dire que c'est pas une bonne
chose
justement pour la question c'est aussi
une question de moyens c'est que quand
on n'a pas les heures pour juste on peut
pas faire de l'accompagnement
personnalisé a pas le temps de le faire
à 30
le point je pense important c'est qu'il
faut faire en sorte que les élèves tous
les élèves qui rentrent en sixième et
qui sorte de troisième sache
parfaitement écrire lire contexte ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
on sait très bien que
aujourd'hui les notes sont bien souvent
surévalués sur des instructions gérer de
souplesse et de tolérance peut-être
bientôt disparaître si besoin est que un
certain nombre d'experts nous disent que
si nous étions noter comme nos parents
ou nos grands parents aujourd'hui
séparés 30 80 % d'élèves qui aurait le
bas ce serait simplement 30% ce qui veut
dire qu'il y a un vrai déficit
d'apprentissage des fondamentaux et de
la transmission par exemple ça ça
démarre au dire un mot sur la méthode
syllabique qui est une bonne méthode
pour apprendre à lire et à écrire est un
éternel voilà mais quelque chose dans la
vie tu as les fondamental et je rappelle
simplement que un bon apprentissage de
la lecture et de l'écriture c'est aussi
une précision de la pensée c'est savoir
évoluer dans un monde différent qui
évolue et par exemple y a pas besoin
d'utiliser forcément des tablettes même
si c'est très bien de le faire mais de
passer tout son temps à des
enseignements pluridisciplinaires où
finalement on perd un peu la trame de ce
qui est le coeur de l'enseignement un
vieux mot clé qui a utilisé qui a été
utilisée par la ministre de l'éducation
c'est égalité plus d'égalité dont le
collège pas de classe d'élite et que
tout le monde ait les mêmes possibilités
justement d'accéder au latin ou grec
quoi d'autres disciplines c'est parce
que vous ressentez vous dans cette
réforme
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
c'est le sens de la réforme je pense que
tout ne se fera pas effectivement en une
année en une année scolaire qu'il faut
le temps que lire les consciences change
aussi parce qu'on est en train de
changer de paradigme de structures de
manière de fonctionner donc il faut le
temps après que les enseignants évoluent
avec eux des élèves aussi les parents
d'élèves s'approprient cette nouvelle
manière de fonctionner mais moi ce qui
m'importe c'est le sens de la réforme et
c'est effectivement remettre de
l'égalité au coeur de l'éducation
contrairement à ce que le modèle que
vous mettez en avant qui moi je trouvais
quelque part un peu caricatural de dire
c'était forcément mieux avant il faut
surtout rien bouger rester sur les mêmes
modalités
alors qu'on voit bien que le monde
évolue que les élèves changent qui est
un besoin de faire évoluer la manière de
transmettre les connaissances
et je pense quoi là c'est ça qui est
vraiment le coeur de la réforme c'est se
tourner vers les élèves parce que je
crois que c'est un mot cap a été
beaucoup prononcer mais se tourner vers
les élèves s'adapter s'adapter à eux et
faire en sorte de d'arrêter de penser
que l'égalité et la démocratisation de
l'accès aux connaissances forcé est
forcément un nivellement vers le bas et
c'est forcément une remise en cause de
l'excellent forte hausse pour un
conclure conclusions moi je suis un
petit peu étonné par certaines choses
que j'ai entendu enfin je rappelle que
dans 80% du volume horaire il y aura un
prof face à une classe qui enseignera
comme il le veut et que 20% du volume
horaire c'est de l'inter disciplinaire
moi je ne crois pas que
l'interdisciplinarité contre
l'excellence bien au contraire je pense
que quand on travaille plus tard et
qu'on a un dossier en charge
on n'étudie pas on ne travaille pas ce
dossier en tranches d'abord je vais
faire des maths de super de l'économie
dessus etc etc
on essaie de saisir le problème de
manière globale est de faire en sorte
que toutes les compétences et toutes les
connaissances puisse nous aider à mener
à bien ce projet je parle de
l'entreprise privée donc en fait le fait
de scinder les choses c'est peut-être
pas forcément une bonne chose sur les
tpe
ouais les ep il à l'enseignement
interdit bien ça peut être des petites
tpe et bien les tpe ça fonctionne en
lice et donc ça pourrait fonctionner en
connaissent je ne vois pas pourquoi ça
ne fonctionnerait pas les collégiens
sont pleins de ressources messiaen 10
secondes vraiment pour conclure du coup
qu'attendez-vous de cette de cette grève
du 17 septembre en retrait tout est à
jeter dans cette réforme non le retrait
maintenant oui puisque le
le gouvernement s'est accroché s'est
accroché à sa façon son écoute et là la
colère des collègues je crois que les
collègues ont un souci celui de la
réussite de leurs élèves à partir du
moment où ils sont confrontés
confronté à une réforme qu'il conteste
qu'il rejette les choses les choses ne
vont pas et donc il ya avec la grève de
jeudi prochain
un moyen pour eux d'exprimer ce rejet de
cette réforme cette colère vraiment pour
terminer en 10 secondes derrière
je pense que si on veut donner vraiment
une égalité des chances à tous il faut
donner des enseignements de qualité donc
il faut revoir de manière très profonde
ce qui se passe dans le dans le collège
et il faut prendre en compte la
diversité des jeunes parce que sinon on
n'arrivera pas à la réussite de tous
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé a cédé 1,13 intéressant donc
rendez vous le 17 septembre pour cette
grève on verra ce que ça donne
on se retrouve nue pour les
manifestations les mots la manifestation
du mois d'octobre
on se retrouve mardi prochain pour un
nouveau 7 8 sociétés n'oubliez pas de
réagir sur le twitter de l'émission à
stoke 7 8 sociétés bonne suite de
programmes sur tv fils